>> POLICE OFFICERS AND EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS BE MANDATE TODAY GET
VACCINES AND IF NOT SHOULD THEY
BE STAY AT HOME OR LET GO?
>> YES AND YES.
THOSE WHO JUST TRY TO MAKE THIS
A POLITICAL ISSUE, FREEDOM.
I HAVE THE FREEDOM TO KILL YOU
WITH MY COVID.
NO, I MEAN, COME ON, FREEDOM.
AINSLEY: PRESIDENT BIDEN
DEMANDING FIRST RESPONDERS WHO
FAILED TO COMPLY WITH VACCINE
MANDATES TO LOSE THEIR JOBS AND
MOCKING PEOPLE TO USE FREEDOMS
NOT TO GET VACCINE AND HERE TO
REACT IS NEW YORK CONGRESSMAN
ELISE STEFANIK.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU,
CONGRESSWOMAN.
CONGRESSWOMAN: GREAT TO BE WITH
YOU, AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: WHAT'S YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU HEAR HIM SAY THAT?
CONGRESSWOMAN: MY REACTION IS
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY ABSURD AND
SADLY IT'S TYPICAL OF JOE BIDEN
TO ATTACK EVERYDAY FREEDOMS.
FIRST OF ALL, THEY ARE TURNING
THEIR BACK ON LAW ENFORCEMENTS
AND FIRST RESPONDERS WHO PUT
THEIR LIVES AND THEIR HEALTH ON
THE LINE EVERY SINGLE DAY
PARTICULARLY DURING THE COVID
PANDEMIC.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN IN NEW YORK
STATE THE CONSEQUENCE OF THESE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL MANDATES WITH
GOVERNOR HOCHUL'S MANDATE
REGARDING VACCINES.
WE HAVE SEEN WALKOUTS AND THIS
IS WHERE OUR HEALTH CARE,
HOSPITALS, COMMUNITY CENTERS ARE
FACING STAFFING SHORTAGES AND IN
MY DISTRICT WE HAVE A RURAL
HOSPITAL THAT'S NO LONGER ABLE
TO DELIVER CHILDREN, DELIVER
BABIES BECAUSE OF THESE
MANDATES.
SO IT'S UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND IT
IS AN ATTACK ON EVERYDAY
FREEDOMS AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE FIGHTING
BACK AGAINST AND I GIVE CREDIT
TO REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY WHO ARE ALSO
CHALLENGING THESE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ANNOUNCEMENTS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION.
AINSLEY: YEAH, AND THERE ARE
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES.
YOU MENTIONED HOSPITAL THAT IS
CAN'T DELIVER BABIES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T HAVE THE WORKERS.
DOCTORS SAID NOT TO GET THE SHOT
SO SHE COULD HAVE A BETTER
CHANCE OF GETTING PREGNANT
BECAUSE SHE WAS WORRIED ABOUT
THAT AND YOU KNOW FOR ME AT
LEAST TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE
WHEN I WANTED TO HAVE A BABY AND
I WANTED A BABY SO BADLY AND IN
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES DON'T YOU
THINK THERE SHOULD BE AN
EXEMPTION?
>> ABSOLUTELY THERE SHOULD BE
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTIONS AND WE WANT
TO ENCOURAGE EVERY AMERICAN TO
HAVE THOSE IMPORTANT
CONVERSATIONS WITH YOUR DOCTOR.
WE ARE PROMOTING VACCINES.
WE HAVE INVESTED IN VACCINES BUT
EVERY PERSON SITUATION IS
DIFFERENT.
IN MANY CASES PEOPLE CONTRACTED
COVID AND HAVE THE NATURAL
IMMUNITY.
SO THERE NEEDS TO BE
FLEXIBILITY.
THESE MANDATES ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND IT'S ATTACK
ON FREEDOMS IN THE COUNTRY AND
TO HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES MOCK FREEDOM,
FRANKLY THAT'S UN-AMERICAN.
AINSLEY: WHAT ABOUT NEW YORK
CITY, THINGS ARE ABOUT TO CHANGE
HERE AFTER BILL DE BLASIO SAID
THERE'S A MANDATE?
CONGRESSWOMAN: WELL, IT'S JUST
ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF NEW YORK CITY
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL WITH
THE FAILED LEADERSHIP FROM MAYOR
DE BLASIO PARTICULARLY AFTER TWO
YEARS WHEN WE'VE SEEN
SKYROCKETING CRIME NUMBERS IN
NEW YORK CITY, THE FACT THAT
HE'S INSTITUTING THE MANDATE FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS, FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND FOR CITY
WORKERS, IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
HUGELY NEGATIVE IMPACT BOTH ON
THE WAY OF LIFE IN NEW YORK CITY
BUT ALSO ON THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY IN NEW YORK CITY.
SO NEW YORKERS HAVE TO STAND UP
AND DEMAND BETTER LEADERSHIP
FROM THEIR MAYORS, FROM THEIR
GOVERNORS AND FROM THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
AINSLEY: THEY WERE OUR HEROES 18
MONTHS AGO AND NOW THEY ARE
POSSIBLY LOSING THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT GOING TO
GET VACCINATED.
I DO WANT TO MENTION THAT YOU
HAD A BABY, BABY SAM AND THIS IS
YOUR FIRST TELEVISION INTERVIEW
SINCE HAVING HIM.
THERE HE IS.
BEAUTIFUL PICTURES.
HOW IS IT GOING?
CONGRESSWOMAN: IT IS GOING
WONDERFUL.
SAM IS JUST A JOY.
AS I HAVE SAID TO YOU BEFORE,
AINSLEY, IT'S LIKE LIFE BEFORE
SAM AND AFTER SAM AND LIFE IS SO
MUCH BETTER AFTER SAM.
HE IS SMILING, HE'S 8 WEEKS
TODAY.
TODAY IS HIS EIGHTH WEEK
BIRTHDAY SO HAPPY BIRTHDAY BABY
SAM FROM MONDAY.
AINSLEY: IS HE SLEEPING THROUGH
THE NIGHT, PROBABLY NOT?
>> NOT QUITE.
HE SLEPT FROM 8:00 TO 2:00 A.M.
BUT I'M EXCITED TO SEE HIM OUT
OF TIME.
AINSLEY: I DO HAVE A DOCTOR THAT
SAYS IF THEY SLEEP 6 HOURS, THEY
CALL THAT SLEEPING THROUGH THE
NIGHT SO YOU GOT YOUR FIRST
NIGHT LAST NIGHT.
CONGRESS CONGRESS ABSOLUTELY.
AINSLEY: WHAT'S THE BEST PART?
CONGRESSWOMAN: THE BEST PART IS
AMOUNT OF LOVE.
YOUR HEART GROWS BY INFINITE
SIZES AND EVERY DAY I LOVE HIM
MORE AND MORE AND IT ALSO IS
AMAZING TO SEE HOW QUICKLY THEY
LEARN AND ABSORB THINGS.
HE CAN RECOGNIZE MY VOICE NOW,
MY -- THEY HAD TURNED ON THE TV
WHEN THEY HAD A PRESS CONFERENCE
WITH MY HOUSE REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AND HE TURNED HIS
HEAD AND RECOGNIZED MY VOICE SO
IT'S JUST SO, SO SPECIAL AND I'M
SO PROUD TO BE HIS MOM.
AINSLEY: YOU ARE TEACHING HIM
ABOUT THE COUNTRY, THE
IMPORTANCE OF HARD WORK BECAUSE
YOU'RE A CONGRESSWOMAN, I DON'T
KNOW HOW YOU'RE BALANCING ALL OF
THIS BUT GOD BLESS YOU AND I
KNOW SAM IS GOING TO HAVE A
WONDERFUL LIFE.
HE'S GOING TO LEARN SO MUCH FROM